welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and this video we're
breaking down secret Invasion the
penultimate entry is now here and
everything's kind of ramped up before we
hit the finale next week throughout this
video we're gonna be recapping what
happens in it all the Easter eggs and
also giving our theories are what Mike
got our next week please smash that like
button and if you're not subscribed then
make sure you do because you don't want
to miss our finale video now last week's
episode ended with Graphics forces
attacking president written's Convoy and
during their say we're disguised as the
Russians thanks to Fury and Talos the
world leader managed to make it out but
these actions unfortunately didn't come
without a cost Talos was killed leaving
fury on his own and he's now lost
everyone due to the Skrill Invasion
Maria is gone his wife can't be trusted
and now as close as Ally has bit the
bullet descending also revealed that
gravic had the extremist powers to him
and that now takes us into the latest
entry
[Music]
thank you
now the episode is titled the Harvest
and this can mean a number of things in
relation to the show when you harvest
something you cultivate the crops and
gather things together just like our
Fury is gathering as allies by that
gravity could be seen as harvesting from
the DNA of the creatures he has in order
to go on and make himself a super scroll
on top of this we also learn about a
program called The Harvest which I'm
guessing is the vial that Fury gets at
the end Captain Obvious but we'll talk
about what's in that more later on in
the video as there's a lot to unpack
with it now we begin in the aftermath of
last week's attack with Fury arriving at
the hospital alongside the president man
he's bloody he's bloody taken off free
free NHS Healthcare get it get him now
this clearly shows why the president
will be replaced by Harrison Ford's
General Ross which we'll talk more about
towards the end of the video we see on
the ukn24 news network that it's making
headline news along with a photo of
Talos in his scroll form the ukn24
network has appeared in the series
before and it's now reporting on the
Panic at the president's motorcade we
can also see see the weather saying
sunny in the U in the UK taking the it's
been been raining nonstoppable all week
mate now Nick knows this will cause some
issues with the planet not the weather
the Scrolls and though Earth has been
attacked by aliens before they haven't
been this close to our world leaders
anyway we cut to Russia and I'm guessing
they got back there so quickly because
of the jet we saw them Landing with in
last week's entry assembling the officer
says they clearly see the campaign as a
failure and we learn more of what
Graphics been up to turns out he did
actually want to steal the Avengers DNA
but it wasn't at any of the sites that
they ended up raiding now this is a line
with the comics as just before Secret
Invasion started the scroll Emperor
kidnapped the Illuminati and took their
DNA Pagan stands up to him finally but
he goes out after aligning slightly with
how he did in the comics that at
imposing his Elektra and he was one of
the first Scrolls that Infiltrate The
Avengers the MCU version has him trying
to steal their DNA but Pagan was
revealed to be a Scroll after fighting a
brainwashed Deco this showed her the
heroes at the Scrolls it up their game
and he was impaled by Echo just like how
he's impelled by gravikir now when he
reverted back into his natural form
everyone was dumbfounded to see one of
their own was actually a scroll and it
blew everyone away previously the
deception had only gone so far and they
weren't able to outsmart telepaths and
people with heightened senses this took
things to the next level low and ensure
that the Scrolls had the ability to
mimic memories which they've also done
in the series now Pagan was pretty much
used as a porn and that's sort of
becoming the case in the show too he and
the Splinter Sally LED in episode 3 all
put their lives on the line to carry out
the Neptune Mission and graphic reveal
this was just something to flush out the
mole if they had launched the missile
and all the people they were playing
would have been looked at more closely
and most likely they would have been
jailed his death clearly rubs the entire
team the wrong way and being called
nameless and faceless makes his inner
circle start to Splinter now this point
he comes up with a crazy plan and he
reaches out to Roadie on the phone if
you stuck around for the credits last
week you'll know that the scroll he's
playing Rowdy is actually called rabba
and this is a character that comes from
the comics someone who speaks about
themselves in the third person which
always annoys Paul but I'm gonna let her
off because both her children died
leaving her thirsty for Revenge dishing
out Carnage in the Galaxy as a pirate
she was eventually given a life sentence
on a deep space torture prison however
here she became allies with several
characters and this actually included
Black Bolt his teleporting Pat lockjaw
came to the rescue and he gave the pair
a way that they could Escape now they
managed to escape and the pair left each
other peacefully this deciding that they
were just going to go their separate
ways in the show we don't know exactly
how long she's been posing is ready for
but Kevin foggy came out and said that
it's beyond just a series he stated that
there's been a number of different
projects but I don't know it kind of
Rob's end game I think if it turns out
he was a scroll I don't know whether
they'll take it all away and do a recast
meta joke but yeah hopefully we get a
clarified exactly when things changed
either way gravic starts telling her the
tip of the president that it was the
Russians and Scrolls and graphic also
talks about how the scrolls are willing
to sacrifice themselves if the plan
doesn't fall in place he's going full on
Jim Jones and again it's gonna
completely kill all the Loyalty that he
has if it gets out now that tell us it's
good at the hands of him the scrolls are
on a very dark path with it potentially
leading right to their Extinction we've
had lip service to this with the Scrolls
before as well as the council talked
about how the cree war was carried out
by Scrolls who refused to back away from
the battle that happened in the case of
gravic's parents who died in the
conflict and he was somewhat and
enamored by their death which is why he
has his death wish here as they arrive
in the hospital we see the other
security guard with his arm and his
sling this was broken by Fury back in
episode 2 and it happened right at the
restaurant man clearly hasn't got time
for Rabbi at this point and he plays his
hand and reveals that he knows Rowdy is
a scroll I love this scene with Rory
threatening Nick and seeing all the gods
standing pointing their guns at him of
course symbolizes that all guns are
aimed at him behind them are the Scrolls
and it cements at those he would
normally look to as the basis of his
allies are standing against him with his
enemies now at this point we go to the
title sequence but for this point of the
video I'm gonna cut to our sponsors I
gotcha cannonballs this summer is not
about the size of those cannonballs yeah
it's about making a splash with our
friends at manscaped get prepped for the
barbecue season with the best hot dogs
anyone's ever seen let the meat speak
for itself with manscape's performance
package 4.0 and go to manscape.com heavy
spoilers and another code heavy spoilers
out check out for 20 off and free
shipping the manscape performance
package 4.0 been used to get for years
now advertising these guys because I
love them so much and they've got
everything you need to make yourself
stand out this summer inside it is a
lawnmower 4.0 got skin safe technology
for trimming a 4K LED spotlight so it
shines your face as you as you're doing
it shines other areas as well that you
might not be able to see that well it's
waterproof too has a travel lock
function when you click it three times
so it locks into place and doesn't set
off when you're on the go it's
absolutely brilliant and you need to
pick one of these up now the kit also
has the weed whacker too I got in
trouble on the last advert from you guys
for for using it on my nose and trimming
on my ears but you could see in action
just how good it was and yeah absolutely
love this piece of Kit as well another
Lifesaver too now that you can feel safe
wearing a low-cut swimsuit without any
stragglers peeking out you can also use
manscape's Liquid formulations that will
bring your balls of brand new freshness
they've got the crop preserver ball
deodorant spray that keeps you cool from
rise to Sunset and it's got a soothing
aloe vera formula that makes it the best
in the business landscape the walls are
thrown in two free gifts and you get the
man escaped anti-chafing boxer briefs
and the shed travel bag take this with
me anytime I go anywhere keeps the kids
safe and yeah packs nicely in my
suitcase and just has it it's got it
secure I don't have to think about it
now it's a treat you should also add in
the crop mops for your balls you know
they're just little wipes that keep
things nice and refreshed hydrated and
yeah they're gonna change your world
that's manscape.com heavy spoilers in
another cold heavy spoilers at checkout
for 20 off and free shipping just go to
the link in the description right now
check out this sweet saver and get
yourself ready for that sweet sweet
summer all right now we came back to
London and see that Fury shooting Maria
has gone viral Sonia realizes that the
time's growing short and though she has
to act fast to get rid of the one in her
ranks this involves her shooting Tony
Kern's character who we saw her meeting
with in episode 1. now shooting him
revealed to the gods that he's actually
a scroll which somewhat riffs on what
happens in the comics in the Savage land
a big battle between the heroes and
Scrolls took place that had the Avengers
not knowing who they could actually
trust because the Scrolls looked exactly
like them they had no idea what was
happening and were wildly outmatched due
to the environment and the fact it was a
fight they couldn't actually test you as
a scroll and if they got up close and
personal it was just gonna be too late
so what Black Widow said was that she'd
just shoot whoever she saw in the Lego
arm and then if they bled purple she'd
know they were a scroll he said she was
just gonna shoot everyone and if you
pushed on it yeah this is probably the
best way to find out who's a scroll and
who isn't I'm not saying you should
shoot the thumbs up button but you know
what to do and Olivia Coleman completely
kills it which makes me hope we see more
of her in the MCU was actually surprised
that he was in last week's entry but she
is an ally that Fury we can now turn to
Sonia is the granddaughter of Union Jack
from The Howling Commandos and the group
she works with might also have things
next week that help set up the future in
the comics we had the team mi-13 and
this dealt with the supernatural stuff
in the Marvel Universe Sonia may end up
being upgraded to them and we are
getting the groundwork laid for them to
appear in the MCU Moon Knight Dane
Whitman and blade were all members are
when we last encountered these
characters they were all in London so
maybe next week we'll end with a tease
to her getting something in mi-13 but
that's a big
[Music]
I love you selfie
now back in Russia we see Beto
questioning Pagan's death and in a nice
little touch we see gravic filling up on
sugar he of course did this when meeting
Talos and just like how Talos used that
as a time to attack his officers do this
too it's pretty violent and they put a
bag over his head before attempting to
suffocate him right on the table man
takes out the old scroll in a scene that
we can't show and clearly the super
scroll Powers leave him able to dominate
them all in battle he kills Beto in
front of the civilians and though he
survives this it's unsure whether his
leadership will now of course doesn't
care because he knows that in a loss
he'll still get the death that he's been
seeking anyway back in London we watch
as Fury goes back to the place where he
welcomed the Scrolls to Earth in episode
2. they were given a new home after
fleeing the war and the location itself
actually has a deeper meaning to it as
Fury says London was badly attacked
during the Blitz in World War II which
could mirror the Scrolls fleeing their
home after the war with the cree Brixton
was actually where the Windrush
generation settled and in case you don't
know this was a group of citizens from
Caribbean countries that were invited to
come to the UK to work and build lives
it was generally seen as a positive time
but decades later the government
somewhat went back on their word and
deported several people against their
rights to them stating they didn't have
the legal right to be here I've done a
far more in-depth discussion on it for
our second episode video but it was a
really controversial thing that made
lots of government ministers end up
resigning because it was such a big
up I don't think it's a stretch to say
that the Scrolls could be a common on
immigration and the promises of a new
home only for this to eventually be
revoked definitely feels like this
location was picked for a specific
reason but yeah let me know below if you
agree or disagree a guy who talks about
how she knows her father died and we
know from the trailers that there was a
scene in which he found his body where
they cut this from the show because it
pretty much gave away in the teasers
that he died so yeah you could have just
left it out completely but it at least
explains how she has his body in the
back of the van either way in case you
miss to our last video the death of
Talos actually has roots in Greek
mythology the figure that was seen as a
leftover from the Bronze Age and all of
the Legends involving him and in his
death this mirrors how Telus is an
example of the Elder Scroll way of
thinking which was to avoid war at all
cost Isha of course has many metaphors
for immigration now we've seen Talus is
somewhat represented the idea how if one
proves their usefulness that they'll be
accepted this was even shown
symbolically in the Scrolls arriving in
Brixton which was also the place that
saw the Windrush generation settling in
Britain a guy is at a point where she's
lost two of her parents due to gravic
and she's gonna have to carry forth the
ideals of Talos which is to avoid
Extinction though last week's show that
she didn't agree with her dad's plans I
think she will end up adopting certain
aspects of it but changed it so that the
Scrolls no longer have to remain in the
shadows I actually think next week might
see it taking on an Abigail brand type
role and she'll end up going to saber
with biryaz's right hand in case you
don't know brands are half aliens slash
off mutant member of Sword who was on
the Pekin secret Invasion when the
scroll masquerading his dum dum Duggan
arrived there and destroyed it tudagaya
gaining those super scroll Powers this
could cover the half mutant part and
she's of course an alien due to her
being a scroll now Maria and tell us
about that I think episode 6 will close
out with them working together on saber
and that she'll appear in some form or
another during the movie the Marvels as
she talks about the original Avengers
DNA which is called the Harvest again
tying back to the title I actually think
Fury might have been attempting to find
a way to clone The Avengers or
potentially he was trying to do his own
Super Soldier program based off their
DNA the only reason that the Hulk even
exists is because they were trying to
redo the super soldier program and maybe
Fury was doing the same thing either way
the police show up and we could to Sonia
delivering a delicious delicious scene
where she meets a Dalton Scrolls getting
the plan through a machine we watch as
she torches the entire place and Guy
Dalton breaks free and takes his wife
hostage however sudden you don't mess
around mate no messing around here and
this could make the scientists you know
more open to giving her Secrets because
she's just saved her life now someone
else with her tensions quite high is
Gaia who alongside talus's body ends up
going to Fury's home she goes past the
masks on the wall which symbolically
have represented how the Scrolls wear
different faces the artwork hanging up
in Fury's home is all being centered
around stuff like this too with some
paintings depicting bodies almost like
they're shape-shifting I know this is
actual art by an actual rspa I think
that this was chosen for a specific
reason anyway Gaia passes by the mask
from last week which Fury actually
managed to shoot directly in the eye he
of course lost his and looking back he
might have purposely hit this as a way
to show what he gave up for Bara he
never actually wanted to kill varicose
of his love for her which is of course
why he purposely missed this was carried
across with her as well and the pair
wanted to easier this conscience if they
managed to shoot them how about them
both missing meant they both live but
this shot in the eye may have been to
remind her of the love they had anyway
she's went to there to get her help to
make a Jedi ceremony for her father
saying goodbye to the Scrolls involves
lighting someone on fire on a funeral
pyre and giving an offering which
involves her mother's wedding ring they
need to say a prayer and we actually
sort of tell us uttering things did the
dead Scrolls in Captain Marvel which
lined up with this I'll swear we see
rather going to tell ritzen about the
scroll facility and this is obviously to
get them to play into gravic's hands he
says England's on board and as we know
the pm here is in fact a scroll which
yeah that the man didn't even understand
how apparel station worked so I'll
believe it now striking Russia would
cause World War III and gravics plans
are all kind of falling into place now
graphic reaches out directly to Nick to
request the Harvest we see Fury also
going on a private jet and shout out to
added a map for realizing that this is
the one that Fury actually wrote in at
the end of Agents of Shield Season 1.
now this is provided to him by none
other than Rick Mason who you might
recognize coming from Black Widow you've
course got Natasha her planes and it
makes sense that he's providing this
here anyway we see guy and Vara
returning to the ladders home to talk
about why she and fury decided to make a
home there it's clear Vara is carrying
anger still over the fact she couldn't
be herself and this was a question she
of course asked Fury last week the
silence is cut short by gunshots though
which kinda ends up kicking everything
up a gear now this shootout in the home
was released as a clip on YouTube last
night and I noticed they're tending to
go with the more action heavy scenes in
the preview cause they obviously want to
hook people look I've seen the viewing
figures and I don't know if that cold
war Espionage Thriller thing they're
going for is is the general audience
Vibes so yeah we need stuff like this
and we can only catch the bullet holes
from the shooting last week but we also
see that Vara has weapons in the lab now
if you're wondering why she had to go to
the safety deposit box for a gun it's
because I think that was instructed by
the Scrolls so she'd have a weapon to
kill Fury with either way the pair of
clearly been playing Modern Warfare and
their adapter clearing out the room
speed reloading and using the noob
Cannon to take people out now from here
we could do a Finnish airport and see
that they're on the lookout for Nick
using one of the masks we saw in both
Winter Soldier and black widow he
manages to go in and sneak past Customs
known as The Widow's cloak I was
surprised this hasn't been brought out
before because we have a way for the
humans to basically shapeshift too this
is of course the skrull's greatest
talent and I think using this would have
helped to even the odds as they could
have even spied on the Scrolls just
seemed like a misstep when the humans
can also change their appearance too and
to be honest I thought this episode was
pretty meh overall just seemed to be
saving everything for the finale next
week and giving us reveals that we
figured out weeks and weeks and weeks
ago and saying that the Harvest is a
pretty interesting idea and we can at
least start a cui fury blames himself he
was the one who sent gravic in to
collect the Avengers DNA and doing this
has now in spiders plan in episode 2 and
talking to the council gravic said he
had a plan for the Avengers and
attempting to get their DNA to copy them
might have been that all along at this
point Nick goes to one of his Graves
which somewhat riffs upon the one that
we saw at the end of winter soldier we
know from what he says that he has
several of these across the planet and
these are something that he's also
implemented in the Marvel Universe known
as dead drops a dead drops the Avengers
game even had them opening up and
revealing underground headquarters here
though they have to scale things back
because they haven't got the budget but
it shows how much Nick has been planning
ahead he's got supply drops laid out
everywhere and probably a different wife
in every different country it's your
fault for not shape-shifting into Naomi
Campbell in the 90s God damn he couldn't
even do that
Sonia asks a very good question which is
why he hasn't called in The Avengers he
says he hasn't got the budget to be
Wheeling Out movie stars for a TV show
constantly and also because this is
personal for him he has to be the person
that planet can rely on otherwise he's
just dust it's obviously yeah obviously
calls back to the ending of infinity War
which in some respects was caused by him
Civil War had the Avengers falling out
and he failed to bring together a United
team that could work together to defeat
Thanos end game showed that if they were
United then they could beat him so some
of the responsibility does rest on his
shoulders and she also says a
Scandinavian Cemetery makes her feel
like she should have brought a scythe
which I think might be a nod to the
seventh seal that was a Swedish have to
make sure I say Swedish film in case
people kick off but the country is part
of the area known as Scandinavia it's a
classic and it actually influenced a lot
of how deaths portrayed in films at this
point the grave lifts up to reveal a
vile while Snick also reveals to Sonia
that he married a scroll I'm guessing
the vial might be too much for gravic
and not in taking it it might end up
killing him might not but either way it
could act as a way for Fury to
completely destroy it as he's probably
realized he shouldn't have this power
because it seems very dangerous now we
did get Clips in the trailer that show
graphic looking like the Hulk and though
people thought this was just the color
obsidian Powers it could be linked in
with the DNA either way Fury putting his
eye patch back on is of course symbolic
and this is very important for a number
of reasons throughout the series they've
talked about how he's out of step and
even his introduction had him stumbling
a bit as he walked to meet Maria here
though he's becoming more and more like
his classic self and how we remember the
character being in his prime Fury
removed the eye patch at the end of The
Winter Soldier and this was to of course
access the data attributed to the second
user account that he'd set up however he
didn't wear it at the end but he did put
it back on for Age of Ultron Avengers
Infinity war and also of course endgame
I'm actually wondering if these will be
revealed to be times Talos was playing
him because let's be honest who wants to
go to a funeral now in the car at the
end of infinity War Maria also called
him Nick which is something they doubled
down on here is showing the person
doesn't really know him far from home
had him wearing it too but as we know
that was actually Talos so yeah I think
it would be interesting if we learned it
actually kept it off since Winter
Soldier as it would add even more
meaning to him putting it back on here
now next week's obviously the finale and
like most MCU shows I'm guessing it's
going to set up a lot of things going
forward in the case of this we actually
know a lot about what's coming down the
line and the Marvel's trailer of course
gave away where Fury was before we even
got to the show he's of course returning
to saber and we know that he's going to
be joined by Monica Rambo as I said
earlier I think guy will be part of this
too and if you cast your mind back to
One Division then you might remember
that a scroll recruit Monica to what we
now know saber so I think Gaia will join
the Scrolls on the ship and they'll then
investigate the anomaly in space we
might even get a hint to something big
going on there and I think we'll get a
tease to what she's looking into there
has been stuff leaked about the Marvels
and what this is and and if you've read
the lead up to secret Invasion then you
might have a fair inkling now on Earth I
think that Humanity might actually have
an adverse reaction to learning that
there are Scrolls Among Us think that
though it's in my try and buy them some
Goodwill that ultimately he's gonna lose
which is why Harris Anderson Ford's
General Ross can come in and take power
we know from this stuff on Captain
America Brave New World that he'll be
playing president Ross unless the power
and politics need to change at some
point now this kind of builds off the
back of the comics but on a grander
scale after the events of Civil War Tony
Stark was the director of Shield
overseeing everything under his watch
the scroll snuck in and this sort of
mirrors how they've infiltrated things
under written when you think about it
his closest advisor was a scroll and
it's gonna end up looking pretty bad for
him now the comics that Norman Osborne
actually they're feeding the Scrolls
leader and he was front and center of
taking them down he was then hired as a
director of shield and from this
position he created the dark Avengers
with a case of President Ross I feel
like he'll make the Thunderbolts and as
we know they're gonna be getting their
own movie Thunderbolt Ross could
definitely be teased at next week and
that's the way I think things are gonna
go externally now internally we have
seen shots of Fury fighting gravig in
the reactor which has been shown in the
trailers my guess is that he's either
trying to destroy the machine or that
this will be used as a way to power
graphic it could even be both and that
will make it not only so that it can be
imprisoned but it'll also stop others
from being created I really really enjoy
graphic you know say what you want about
the show so I hope he stays around and
even if they don't depower him just send
him to the raft so yeah that's my
thoughts on the series and what I think
is gonna happen in it and obviously I'd
love to hear your thoughts too so make
sure you drop them below please hit the
thumbs up button and if you want to
support the channel as a member of the
spoiler Society then please hit join you
get early access to videos every week
and it goes such a long way to keeping
us independent and also helping us out
now if you want something else to watch
you've got a video on screen right now
going over all the Deadpool leaks and
all the updates we have definitely head
over there if you're curious about that
Marvel's post-credits scene as we go
into it in more detail and yeah
hopefully I see you over there right
after this by the way huge thank you for
taking us through the video I've been
your host Paul and I'll see you next
time take care peace